Priscilla riziki has been looking for
her daughter husband and three children
they were living at a ranch in chakahola
along the Kenyan Coast more than 100
bodies have been found from shallow
graves in the area
I know the survivors because I was part
of the congregation I have asked if they
have seen my family but they are not
talking
a pastor named Paul mckenzindenge is in
police custody accused of luring his
followers to stir themselves to death in
the hope of entering Heaven according to
the Red Cross 400 people are still
missing half of them are children
Pathologists are carrying out autopsies
to determine the cause of death
authorities here are looking for more
remains many Kenyans are still in shock
they are asking how this incident went
so long before being detected acted the
pastor himself is very well known by the
police he has been arrested several
times some rights groups say they had
received reports of extreme fasting in
shakahola as early as February they
accused a police of not responding fast
enough we didn't hear from them so we
decided to go back again and later on
decided to act because of the human race
Center we thought it was a place where
these congregants are with the fact that
we were so that they were starving or
they were fasting then it wasn't a
harmful Place sort of so we decided to
visit the place without the authorities
and then when we went there some of our
members were actually attacked
the number of people who have been
rescued is dwindling while the bodies
are still piling up riziki is still
hoping for the best by preparing for the
worst Catherine soy chakahola kilifi
County